.
THANK YOU, SENATOR.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Brian: YOU GOT IT MEANWHILE,
REMEMBER WHETHER JOE BIDEN SAID
WE WOULDN'T LEAVE ANYONE BEHIND
IN AFGHANISTAN?
>> AMERICANS SHOULD UNDERSTAND
THE TROOPS MIGHT HAVE TO BE
THERE BEYOND AUGUST 31st.
>> NO.
AMERICANS SHOULD UNDERSTAND THAT
WE ARE GOING TO TRY TO GET IT
DONE BEFORE AUGUST 31st.
>> BUT IF WE DON'T THE TROOPS
WILL STAY.
>> IF WE DON'T WE WILL DETERMINE
AT THE TIME WHO IS LEFT.
>> AND?
>> AND IF THERE ARE AMERICAN --
IF THERE IS AMERICAN CITIZENS
LEFT, WE ARE GOING TO STAY UNTIL
WE GET THEM ALL OUT.
>> Brian: HE HAD TO BE PRODDED
TO SAY THAT, BUT SHOULDN'T HE BE
FORCED TO BACK UP HIS WORD?
THAT'S WHAT SENATOR JOSH HAWLEY
FOUND OUT THAT, IN FACT, THE
PRESIDENT DID NOT LIVE UP TO
THAT STATEMENT AT ALL.
>> ISN'T IT TRUE THAT YOU HAVE
LEFT AMERICANS BEHIND ON AUGUST
THE 31st?
>> THERE ARE AMERICANS, THERE
WERE AMERICANS THAT WERE STILL
IN AFGHANISTAN AND STILL ARE.
>> Brian: YES.
THE ANSWER IS YES.
HOW HARD IS IT TO SAY YES.
YOU LEFT HUNDREDS, IF NOT
THOUSANDS BEHIND.
HERE TO REACT ARE LIEUTENANT
COLONEL SCOTT MANNING WHO TRIED
TO GET HIM OUT HIMSELF FORMER
GREEN BERET AND FOUNDER OF TASK
FORCE BINE APPLE SEAN PARNELL
AND PENNSYLVANIA SENATE
CANDIDATE.
I WILL START WITH YOU, SCOTT.
OF COURSE WE LEFT PEOPLE BEHIND.
YOU WOULDN'T HAVE TO SCRAMBLE,
GIVE UP YOUR JOB, PUT TOGETHER A
TASK FORCE AND TRY TO GET THEM
OUT AS A RETIRED GUY.
DID THAT OUTRAGE YOU?
THANKS, BRIAN FOR HAVING ME ON.
WHAT'S FRUSTRATING TO SO MANY OF
OUR RETIRED VETERANS RIGHT NOW
THERE ARE STILL THOUSANDS OF AT
RISK AFGHANS WHO ARE BEING
HUNTED AND EXECUTED RIGHT NOW.
LOOK, THERE ARE PARTNER SPECIAL
OPERATIONS FORCES FROM THE
COMMANDOS AND AFGHAN SPECIAL
FORCES AND AFGHAN INTERPRETERS
THAT FOUGHT UNTIL THE LAST
BULLET.
THE LAST BULLET.
NOW THEY ARE BEING HUNTED DOWN
AND WE ARE JUST FOCUSED ON
ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO TO WORK
WITH THE GOVERNMENT AND PRIVATE
SECTOR TO GET THEM OUT ANY WAY
THAT WE CAN.
>> Brian: SCOTT, IT'S
UNBELIEVABLE, SEAN PARNELL,
BECAUSE YOU FOUGHT OVER THERE
YOU PUT YOUR LIFE ON THE LINE
OVER THERE YOUR FRIEND LOST
THEIR LIVES OVER THERE.
NOW YOU HAVE THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
ALLIED OR CLOSE TO YOU RUNNING
FOR THEIR LIVES.
WE DON'T EVEN HAVE A PLAN OR AS
SENATOR BLUMENTHAL REQUESTED
SOME TYPE OF CZAR IN CHARGE OF
GETTING PEOPLE OUT.
ONE BY ONE.
WE HAVE TO DO IT ONE BY ONE.
>> YEAH.
IT'S AN UNBELIEVABLE SLAP IN THE
FACE, BY THE WAY, TO ANYBODY WHO
HAS SERVED THIS COUNTRY FOR THE
LAST 20 YEARS TO HAVE JOE BIDEN
TROT OUT TO THE PODIUM AND CALL
THE WITHDRAWAL OR SURRENDER,
REALLY IN AFGHANISTAN AN
EXTRAORDINARY SUCCESS.
AND JOE BIDEN, BY THE WAY, HE
INTENDED TO LIE AND DECEIVE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE FROM DAY ONE ON
AFGHANISTAN.
LOOK NO FURTHER THAN HIS
CONVERSATION WITH PRESIDENT
GHANI OF AFGHANISTAN IN LATE
JULY WHERE HE TRIED CONVINCE
PRESIDENT GHANI TO TELL THE
WORLD THAT THE TALIBAN WAS NOT
AS STRONG AS WE KNEW THAT THEY
WERE.
AND IN EXCHANGE FOR MILITARY AID
FROM THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
SO JOE BIDEN INTENDED TO DECEIVE
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ALL ALONG.
AND AS A RESULT, WE ARE SEEING
THIS DISASTROUS SURRENDER IN
AFGHANISTAN.
WE GOT AMERICANS LEFT BEHIND.
THOUSANDS OF OUR ALLIES LEFT
BEHIND.
ONE OF OUR FINAL ACTS IN
AFGHANISTAN WAS KILLING AN AIDE
WORKER AND SEVEN CHILDREN AND
WHAT BLOWS ME AWAY BEYOND ALL OF
THIS IS THAT NO ONE HAS BEEN
HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Brian: I KNOW.
>> UNBELIEVABLE TO ME THAT THE
ONLY PERSON THAT'S BEEN HELD
ACCOUNTABLE IS LIEUTENANT
COLONEL IN THE MARINE CORPS
FRONT TOWARDS ENEMY SIMPLY
CALLED FOR ACCOUNTABILITY IN A
VERY PROFESSIONAL WAY HE IS IN
JAIL TONIGHT AND THAT'S
UNACCEPTABLE.
>> Brian: UNTIL HIS TRIAL COMES
UP.
WE HOPE TO TALK TO HIS PARENTS
TOMORROW.
1K09, I KNOW YOU WORK WITH THE
DEFENSE DEPARTMENT YOU DON'T
WANT TO BURN ANY BRIDGES I
UNDERSTAND THAT.
TODAY THE THEY SAY STATE IS
HANDLING IT.
YOU KNOW THE STATE DEPARTMENT
HAS BEEN NO HELP.
WE HAVE 10,000 PEOPLE WHO HAVE A
REASON TO SAY THEY HELPED
AMERICA AND LEGITIMATE
AMERICANS.
WHAT IS YOUR PLAN OF ACTION AND
YOUR MESSAGE TO WASHINGTON?
>> YEAH.
I WOULD JUST SAY THAT WE HAVE
ACTUALLY GOT TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF AT RISK AFGHANS RIGHT NOW,
BRIAN, THAT HAVE NO WAY OUT IF
THE PRIVATE SECTOR AND THE
PUBLIC SECTOR DOESN'T CONTINUE
TO WORK TOGETHER ON THIS.
MY CONCERN IS THAT THE ONLY
CONVERSATION ON THIS RICE RIGHT
NOW IS WHAT WENT WRONG.
BELIEVE ME, I BELIEVE THAT
CONVERSATION HAS TO HAPPEN AND I
THINK IT WILL HAPPEN AND YOU ALL
ARE PRESSING THAT WHAT I ALSO
WORRY ABOUT IS WHAT ARE WE DOING
RIGHT NOW.
>> Brian: I KNOW.
>> TO GET OUT THE TENS OF
THOUSANDS THAT WE MADE A
COMMITMENT TO.
THAT'S WHERE I THINK WE NEED TO
CONTINUE NOT JUST A
CONVERSATION, BUT MEANINGFUL
ACTION THAT SHOWS HOW WE ARE
GETTING THEM OUT, MOVING THEM
ANYWAY THAT WE CAN RIGHT NOW
THAT SEEMS TO BE SLIPPING AWAY
IN THE NEWS AND IN THE
CONVERSATION AND THAT WORRIES ME
MORE THAN ANYTHING.
>> Brian: WE HAVE GOT HEAR ABOUT
PEOPLE GETTING OUT AND HAVE
PEOPLE SITTING ON EITHER SIDE OF
YOU AND YOU TELLING ME HOW THEY
DID IT AND THE LAND BRIDGE THAT
WORKED AND WE'RE NOT THERE YET.
SEAN PARNELL, DO ME A FAVOR, WIN
THE ELECTION GET ON THE ARMED
SERVICES COMMITTEE GETTING ON
THESE GUYS AND HOLD THESE WOMEN
ACCOUNTABLE.
>> YOU CAN BET THAT I WILL,
BRIAN.
ONE OF WILL BE HOW REREFORM
SELECT AND PROMOTE GENERAL
OFFICERS.
RIGHT NOW I THINK AT THE TOP
ECHELONS OF OUR MILITARY TOO
MANY LEADERS CONCERNED WITH
THEIR BOUGH AND NOT THEIR WAKE.
WE NEED RECOGNITION SERVICE AT
THE CORE OF EVERYTHING WE DO IN
THE MILITARY AND NEVER LEAVING
AMERICANS BEHIND.
>> Brian: MY MESSAGE TO THE NEXT
OCHAIRMAN OF THE JOINT CHIEFS OF
STAFF FROM BOB WOODWAR